lyon et il n'y aura pas de chasse aux
sorcières que les partisans du rhdp se
rassurent nous n'avons pas les
poursuivre pour les fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près d ivoire
[Musique]
au printemps il verra t-on équipements
et le cas sera un morceau roumanie et
aux assauts t il prendre à ton âme ce
qui est puis je fais tu as qui est dit
[Musique]
avant il y avait trois chaman maintenant
ils sont beaucoup les pèlerins ceux qui
sont venus pour un service de prières
par là
il
oh
[Musique]
on
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi aujourd'hui
est l'essentiel de l'information avec
nos invités et nos reporters sur le
terrain tout de suite les grands titres
de l'actualité de ce mercredi 7 octobre
le personnel soignant toujours en
première ligne face à un regain de
l'épidémie et la colère ne retombe pas
alors que les promesses du ségur de la
santé tarde à se concrétiser
fatigue charge de travail manque
d'effectif des difficultés à recruter
elle les griefs ne manquent pas pour un
hôpital qui a toutes les difficultés à
maintenir le navire à flot emmanuel
macron l'assuré encore hier en visite à
l'hôpital rothschild à paris
je ne veux pas laisser tomber l'hôpital
[Musique]
l'ancienne candidate à l'élection
présidentielle biélorusse svetlana
tirano sky a s'est exprimé ce matin
devant les députés à l'assemblée
nationale
l'opposante remercie le gouvernement
pour son soutien salut les sanctions
européennes et précise ce qu'elle
attendait encore de la france
une intervention en visioconférence au
lendemain de sa rencontre avec la
chancelière allemande angela merkel
[Musique]
toujours aucune officialisation de la
part du gouvernement d'une éventuelle
libération de l'otage français sophie
petrona en échange de dizaines de
jihadistes
alors que la veille sa famille se disait
confiance son fils présents à bamako a
affirmé ce matin avoir toujours aucune
certitude sur le sort de sa mère enlevée
en 2016 hommen
[Musique]
la grogne des soignants toujours vives
comme on a pu le constater ce mardi lors
de la visite des manuels macron à
l'hôpital rothschild à paris
le personnel hospitalier dénonce un plus
de fric pour l'hôpital public proclame
une banderole déployée par les soignants
qui font face au président de la
république alors que la deuxième vague
de coronavirus frappe désormais le pays
les départs de l'hôpital public pour le
privé ou tout autre domaine
professionnel se multiplient pourtant
selon le chef de l'état de l'argent il y
en a il y a eu tout un travail qui a été
fait quand même qui a permis d'aboutir
sur le ségur de la santé ce sont en
effet des actes ce ne sont pas que des
mots
c'est plus de 8 milliards
d'investissements par an ce qui n'a
jamais été fait jamais en septembre les
paramédicaux et les agents techniques
des hôpitaux publics et privés ont
touché 90 euros nets supplémentaires à
partir de mars 2021
leur fiche de paie affichera encore 93
euros nets de plus mais ces
augmentations de salaires suffisent
elles à un personnel soignant qui doit
s'adapter aux démissions qui claire sème
ses rangs on peut pas aller travailler
dans un service de réanimation du jour
au lendemain ça c'est pas faisable c'est
trop complexe et trop technique que ses
maîtres le passé en manger et mettre le
soigner en danger également
on n'est pas des pions on est à là on
est des humains et donc si on respecte
en tant qu'humain et caution nous écoute
peut-être qu'à ce moment là ils
arriveront à retrouver du personnel pour
venir travailler
il faut arrêter de croire qu'il faut
nous appeler le à 17h devenir un travail
à 19 heures on a une vie de famille on
est déçu mais on a une vie de famille on
a des enfants on a démarré s'ils sont
encore là s'ils sont toujours restés il
faut écouter les soignants visiblement
l'attractivité à l'emploi escomptée par
le ségur de la santé n'a pas rencontré
un franc succès dégoûté par la
technostructure les jeunes soignants
quitte l'hôpital
trente quatre mille postes d'infirmières
vacants en réaction l'ap-hp décide de
presser le citron des soignants qui
reste passage en dix ou douze heures par
jour et à 48 heures par semaine fatigue
gare aux erreurs de soins pour
rééquilibrer les effectifs
l'assistance publique des hôpitaux de
paris ap hp lance une opération
séduction pour faire face à la deux
vagues dans 39 hôpitaux franciliens 500
postes d'infirmiers ou d'aides-soignants
ce sont ouverts avec des conditions de
travail améliorées prime d'installation
places en crèche
l'assistance publique des hôpitaux de
marseille ap hm recherche également 200
infirmières une perte de motivation
générale face à un quotidien toujours
plus complexe à gérer en raison de la
crise du colis de 19 et des promesses
qui tarde à se concrétiser alors des
soignants qui quittent les hôpitaux
malgré des promesses du gouvernement est
ce la cause de la première vague qui a
eu raison de leur dévouement et c'est
plutôt lié à un écoeurement face à un
gouvernement qui n'a pas tenu ses
promesses
comment y remédier c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jean-paul à mon médecin généraliste
président d'honneur de la fédération des
médecins de france bonsoir à vos côtés
arnaud chiche anesthésistes fondateur du
collectif santé en danger
bonsoir nous a rejoint également alexis
poulain éditorialistes bonsoir alors
pour commencer alexis poulain votre
réaction alors il ya les soignants en
colère mais pas seulement
selon un sondage hélas paru aujourd'hui
61 % des français considèrent qu
emmanuel braqueront n'a pas été à la
hauteur de la situation depuis le début
de la crise du coronavirus 55% pensent
qu'il n'a pas pris les bonnes décisions
sur le plan sanitaire
c'est très sévèrement alexis poulain oui
c'est sévère mais il faut voir la façon
dont cette crise a été extrêmement mal
géré on attendait en temps de crise un
état stratège
on avait un état cabinet de consulting
ou finalement les responsables dans les
ministères et à l'elysée n'ont pas su
comment réagir face à cette crise alors
il ya eu un conseil scientifique qui
conseillait mais ont manqué tous les
masques qui étaient absents les
matériels de protection des soignants
qui a été absent les soignants qui
demandait de l'aide qui n'en recevait
pas les cliniques privées qui demandait
à être mobilisés qui n'étaient pas
mobilisées
il n'y a eu aucune planification aucune
organisation de la réponse de l'état à
cette crise majeure
ça a été une improvisation du jour 1
jusqu'à encore maintenant aujourd'hui
malgré l'expérience de la première vague
et pourquoi
et bien tout simplement parce que l'état
a failli l'état n'existent plus parce
que les les énarques qui sortent
maintenant de promotion de l'ena préfère
faire carrière dans la banque assurance
dans la finance
plutôt que de venir des hommes d'état et
où des hauts fonctionnaires et tous ce
problème là de la non planification
arrive à la fin parce que c'est une
logique celle du néo management public
qui voudrait que les services publics
n'existe plus que l'état finalement soit
uniquement un ogre régaliens justice
police et puis à peu près tout et que
l'hôpital ne soit plus un service public
loin de là mais répondre aux mêmes
logiques que le privé c'est depuis des
années les plans de santé qui se sont
accumulés et puis on a vu une stratégie
inventé par emmanuel macron pour gérer
la pénurie les masses n'étant pas là il
était inutile
or les masques il était très utile lors
du h1n1 qui était également un virus a
est reporté à l'époque il était dans le
protocole sanitaire à l'époque ils ont
été effacées du protocole sanitaire
parce qu'on en avait pas
cette année et tout est comme ça et on
continue aujourd'hui les ars continue de
supprimer des lits alors qu'on a besoin
de lits alors qu'on voit bien que la
santé c'est pas quelque chose qui peut
se monnayer c'est pas quelque chose qui
doit rentrer dans les cases du profit
alors en tout cas emmanuel macron était
hier à la rencontre des soignants il a
justifié
certaines de ces hausses de ses
décisions il est à l'hôpital rothschild
dans le 19e arrondissement de paris
l'occasion pour remercier les personnels
soignants on regarde et on en parle
je tiens à vous remercier
poignant
pour ce qui est fait depuis des années
et des années ce qui est fait aussi
aujourd'hui parce que beaucoup parfois
on oublie alors au cours de ce
déplacement le chef de l'état a défendu
le ségur de la santé ce ne sont pas des
promesses c'est un accord a martelé le
chef de l'état devant des soignants
sceptiques
jean paul hamon vous les comprenez ces
soignants sceptiques
écoutez je comprend d'autant mieux les
soignants celtique que ça fait un moment
que le coq système par radeau et puis je
rappellerai quand même au président qu
un système de santé qui marche c'est un
système qui marche sur ses deux jambes
la médecine libérale la médecine de
ville qui qui permet d'éviter les
hospitalisations inutiles qui permet
d'éviter et d'envoyer des personnes
âgées dans les ehpad le vendredi soir
parce que vendredi soir à cause des 35
heures vous avez une infirmière
intérimaire qui peut joindre aucun
médecin et qui au grande part appuyé qui
envoie la personne âgée à l'hôpital et
qui ramène accessoirement qu'ovide à la
maison et donc dans l'ehpad
donc vous avez un système qui ne marche
pas sur ses deux jambes et et c'est bien
il faut réorganiser l'hôpital mais il
faut faire une vraie communication entre
la ville et l'hôpital que la ville ait
les moyens d'éviter les hospitalisations
et de prendre en charge et
d'hospitalisation les retours rapides à
la maison voilà ce qu'il faut faire
or quand vous voulez et quand vous
prétendez réformer un système de santé
et que vous êtes vous fait que l'hôpital
naturellement c'est un système qui ne
sert qu'à qu'à creuser le déficit et
vous ré organisé par le système de soins
il faut éduquer les patients au bon
usage de l'hôpital vous avez 20 millions
de passages qui se font aux urgences qui
n'ont strictement rien à y faire d'après
l'igas et 20 millions de passages ça
pourrait être largement pris en charge
par la médecine de ville
on est en train d'essayer de faire
comprendre avec le service d'accès aux
soins que la régulation de d'aider des
personnes âgées des personnes qui
veulent soins non programmés en journée
pourrait être pris en charge par la
médecine libérale
pourvu qu'on accepte que qu'elle se
réorganise comme on le propose et non
pas un numéro d'appel unique qui qui qui
ne va à cuba site strictement servir à
rien alors avant de vous donner la
parole à arnaud chiche
je voudrais qu'on jette un coup d'oeil à
cet article paru ce matin dans le canard
enchaîné
il est intitulé la déprime des primes
ont regardé vous nous en parler
de plus en plus forte ces primes
qu'ovide non seulement des milliers de
soignants n'ayons pas eu droit
mais d'autres qui les ont touchés sont
priés de les rembourser
motif l'administration s'est trompé pour
palper les 1500 euros de bonus il
fallait avoir travaillé dans certains
services et pas dans d'autres
à certaines dates et pas à d'autres et
tant pis pour les victimes de cette
usine à gaz
or voilà une information qui interroge
arnaud chiche vous êtes citées dans cet
article est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé précisément
oui je suis cité dans cet article parce
que c'est moi qui ai donné toutes les
informations qu'elle a enchaîné
donc je remercie le canard enchaîné
d'avoir cité le collectif sont en danger
si vous voulez dans le cocktail abject
de la prise en charge des soignants en
2020 en france il ya eu aussi le
chapitre des primes
c'est à dire que effectivement les
conditions pour pouvoir toucher la prime
elle était très resserrée très précise
et si vous n'y étiez pas jouer alors je
n'ai plus les détails en tête mais il
fallait être entre certaines dates
exactement ça jouer parfois un jour près
si vous n'aviez pas là si vous manquez
le jour j la prime était reprise mais
vous savez ça en fait c'est très
intéressant parce que quand on canton de
nous intéresser au système des primes co
lead et de ce scandale absolu
vous avez tout à fait la vision qu'a
l'état des soignants et vous avez tout à
fait les recettes de la manière dont est
traité la santé en france
alors je vais vous dire une chose je
merci dr amont je vous ai écouté avec
attention et je pense exactement comme
vous surtout ce que vous allez d'y faire
un c ur de la santé sur l'hôpital ça ne
sert à rien il fallait faire un centre
un cigare sur la santé total ne les
connaître la snet in de ville
ça ne sert à rien c'est une
méconnaissance totale du système de
santé en france et vous laisser vous qui
l'avez dit monsieur vous avez parlé de
cabinet de consulting
effectivement s'il faut faire du
consulting en france pour organiser la
santé je vous conseille d'inviter le
docteur à mon jeu je me connais aussi un
petit peu et lui et moi je suis certain
qu'on fera beaucoup mieux que ce
ministère qui ne fait n'importe quoi
concernant les primes concernant le
match
ariel concernant les tests et qui se dit
le 7 octobre
comment on va faire pour absorber cette
crise parce que cette crise d'octobre à
risque d'être pire qu'en mars juge
étonnamment rien n'a été fait justement
arnaud chiche en juillet dernier 8,1
milliards d'euros ont été débloqués pour
l'hôpital public olivier ferrand avait
promis 15 mille embauches au moment du
soccer de la santé 7500 recrutement pour
pourvoir les postes vacants 7500 postes
supplémentaires alors arnaud chiche dans
les faits on en est où aujourd'hui mais
monsieur olivier ferrand il peut
promettre tout ce qu'il veut il peut
promettre 50 il passe t'il si il ne
touche pas aux salaires des soignants
haut niveau qui est nécessaire c'est à
dire 300 euros et passes en 81 s'il ne
s'intéresse pas aux effectifs dans les
établissements de santé
si le s'intéresse pas aux ratios une
infirmière pour combien de patients
s'ils ne s'intéressent pas de près mais
moi si ma gamine elle me dit un jour
qu'elle est infirmière je lui dis mais
ne fais jamais ça
allez voir dans les ehpad qui se passe
le cieux les ehpad
c'est un scandale d'état comme il ya pas
assez de personnel on diminue le
personnel le week end comprenez donc en
fait la toilette et les l'intimité des
personnes âgées alitées le week-end
c'est moi c'est moi important quand on
peut créer cinquante mille postes
il faut donner envie aux gens de faire
ce métier la tête un métier formidable
formidable mais aujourd'hui les jeunes
est ce que vous croyez qu'ils ont envie
d'aller prendre un job où ils vont
risquer leur vie parce qu'on n'en parle
pas assez de ça je rappelle qu'en mars
et de 70 morts en france 1 parmi les
soignants et pas des gens très âgés un
des mères de famille des jeunes médecins
retraités qui étaient venus aider on
n'en parle pas c'est moi j'ai envie d'en
entendre parler tous les jours
donc en fait aujourd'hui avec des
conditions très mauvaises
on voudrait que les gens viennent mais
ces gens-là ils croient au père noël
c'est vrai comme ça que ça se passe jean
paul hamon justement pour reprendre ce
métier de soignant à attractif pour le
rendre attractif comment on fait
aujourd'hui selon vous on évite de
prendre des arrêtés comme celui qui a
été pris le 6 mars en pleine pandémie
par je ne sais qui au ministère
permettant
aux infirmières et aux pharmaciens
d'apprendre à palper les lombaires dans
le cadre des infections urinaires avec
une formation de quatre heures alors si
vous voulez quand vous voyez ça que vous
découvrez sa après la pandémie parce que
vraiment au mois de mars on avait autre
chose à [ __ ] que de regarder s'est
arrêté des ministères
cc la médecine c'est la médecine en dix
jours vous apprenez à regarder une gorge
en trois heures à écouter un coeur en
trois heures à palper les lombaires en
quatre heures
ces gens là sont complètement paniqué
parce que la france est en train de se
désertifier de sa médecine libérale et
de sa médecine de proximité tous les
français savent quelles difficultés ils
ont à trouver un médecin traitant moi je
suis dans une commune
on a perdu on a perdu six médecins
généralistes et y en a quatre qui
exercent qui ont plus de 70 ans dont moi
donc je peux vous dire que la france est
en train de se désertifier et et on a
une administration qui pensent que en
déléguant toutes les tâches tous les
actes qu'ils pensent simples qui sont en
train de dégrader la qualité de prise en
charge des patients je peux vous dire
que les internes qui viennent chez moi
dans mon cabinet se demande quel métier
mon examen qui vont exercer
quand on sait que les pharmaciens vont
traiter entre guillemets les angines qui
vont traiter les infections urinaires
après avoir palpé les lombaires ou après
a appris à palper les lombaires pendant
quatre heures que la téléconsultation on
va se déployer avec des plateformes de
téléconsultation kivu siphonne vos
données médicales et vous donner tout
court d'octo libre qui se mêlent de
faire de la de la téléconsultation avec
une dégradation de la qualité de prise
en charge du patient parce que vous êtes
pris en charge en télé consultation par
un médecin qui ne vous connaît pas donc
et là on voit que entre la
téléconsultation les transferts de
tâches etc
on voit que lala lala une dégradation
constante de la qualité de prise en
charge des patients une france qui se
désertifient et des jeunes médecins qui
se disent mais quel médecin quel métier
on va exercer
quand en plus après une crise majeure
comme celle là qu'on avait l'occasion
unique de réformer le système de santé
on se contente de bricoler une rumeur
d'une mesure hâtif sur l'hôpital même
s'il ya de l'argent effectivement qui
est mis mais effectivement je comprends
les soignants parce que effacer la dette
de l'hôpital de 10 milliards c'est bien
ça peut-être permet d'apt être
d'investir mais mais en tous les cas le
il voit pas l'argent arrivé sur leur
compte alors alexis poulain justement à
propos d'argent et manuellement
frontières l'a dit ce n'est pas une
question de moyens mais une question
d'organisation est ce que vous partagez
ce constat du président pour l'hôpital
pas du tout d'ailleurs c'est un problème
l'organisation ce sont les cabinets de
conseil en organisation que ce soit les
mac kinsey les bayne les parts ayant y
voyez et autres qui sont à l'origine du
manque d'argent de l'hôpital parce
qu'ils ont fait de l'hôpital public de
la santé un centre de profit et ces gens
là sont à la manoeuvre depuis des années
derrière les plans déficiences des
hôpitaux
c'est eux qui ne connaissent pas le
métier il est temps que les médecins
reprennent le pouvoir et vire les
comptes de tous les cabinets de
consulting
ça suffit c'est les médecins qui doivent
faire la santé c'est pas des gens qui
parce que c'est un marché important vont
expliquer aux politiques qui sont là
parce que voilà on les a élus mais
parfois on se demande pourquoi comment
faire pour faire de l'argent économisé
de l'argent on se rend bien compte que
la santé publique
elle coûte de l'argent mais qu'elle ne
peut fonctionner qu'effectivement la
médecine libérale est en bonne forme il
ya vous avez au sein des chantres de la
start up nation des gens qui pensent
qu'on peut faire sans argent avec de
l'innovation
je suis désolé en réanimation il ya eu
très peu d'innovation ces vingt
dernières années
les médicaments sont les mêmes on a
besoin de bras de lits et de médecins
qui font des diagnostics en amont pour
que justement arrive en réanimation le
moins de gens possible qu'ils soient
traités en amont par des médecins
libéraux par exemple et qu'il ne soit
pas ni aux urgences ni dans des lits de
réanimation et ça c'est pas l'innovation
technique c'est pas effectivement la
lettre de télé consulting de d'octo
l'ibu ce genre de truc qui va faire
qu'on va faire des bons diagnostics
c'est des médecins c'est à dire arrêtez
avec le numerus clausus former
correctement les gens paient
correctement les soignants dans
l'hôpital public
donc oui si on met des milliards sur la
table c'est pour recruter des gens c'est
pas pour inventer encore un truc comme
stop qu'ovide ou des applications
miracle qui vont servir à rien à part
rationaliser les les responsables du
désastre actuel sont ceux qui font du
conseil
et ils sont encore à la manoeuvre c'est
eux qui font de ségur de la santé c'est
le cabinet de ben & consulting qui fait
le déconfinement au nom de jean castex
voilà donc les tableaux excel ça suffit
maintenant faisons confiance aux
médecins ils savent ce qu'il faut pour
que la santé fonctionne en france alors
juste
on a deux médecins on va pouvoir
s'intéresser à la stratégie sanitaire du
gouvernement avec toujours cette
question des tests elle a été mise en
avant par le gouvernement avec le nombre
très nombreux tests effectués chaque
semaine
alors on ne sait pas s'ils sont positifs
mais contagieux ou pas ça on sais pas
encore je vous propose d'écouter
alexandra aurions codalet généticienne
ancienne directrice directrice de
l'inserm elle était sur ce plateau lundi
soir on écoute lorsqu'on est positif on
va avoir entre voilà cinquante pour 60%
certains disent 90% de chances de ne pas
être porteur de moindre symptôme
donc on est en train de parler de cas
quand finalement la majorité
vous avez dit 62% certains 10,90
qu'importe n'allons pas dans les
chiffres la majorité est véritablement
150 donc sans qu vide
il ya plusieurs raisons à cela c'est
qu'en fait on demande à ce test de nous
renseigner sur ce qui ne peut pas faire
c'est à dire la contagiosité ordo chiche
sur cette question des tests de la
contagiosité qu'on ne sait pas encore
mesurer
on en est où aujourd'hui effectivement à
ce que c'est une piste qu'on doit
creuser selon vous écoutez je je je
pense sincèrement que la stratégie du
dépistage d'isoler de d'identifier les
cas contacts et sur le papier une bonne
stratégie
je trouve que effectivement ça peut
avoir du sens mais mais il faut que les
moyens soient mis en regard avec soit
mieux en soit à peu près à la hauteur de
cette organisation
or qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on s'est
lancés en dépistage massif médiatique de
tel ou tel quartier ça n'avait aucun
sens on a gâché des réactifs ce qui fait
que la situation
mi-septembre 5 septembre alors là je
sais pas il paraît que ça va un peu
mieux mais il faut que je vérifie aussi
ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé la main moi
dans mon entourage dans l'eau de france
lille quand même hein qu'est la
troisième ou la quatrième ville de
france pour prendre un rendez-vous
c'était une semaine de délai parfois et
le résultat c'était une semaine à dix
jours
avec une stratégie comme ça vous fait
rien alors là c'est pareil c'est pareil
je ne sais pas d'où ça vient mais celui
qui a imaginé faire des tests massif
alors qu'on n'a pas assez de réactifs
cas pressurisée les laboratoires il faut
voir le mal être du personnel des labos
les files d'attentes l'angoissent le
côté anxiogène que ça crée dans les
familles de papa à moi et moi dans ma
famille ma play arts nous on a besoin de
se faire tester
alors moi j'arrivais à les faire tester
parce qu'on passait par par des chemins
détournés
je triche est un peu mais cissé s'est
complètement ça n'a pas été décidée par
des médecins c'est pas possible
donc en fait mille fois d'accord avec
vous monsieur l'éditorialiste ce poulain
oui bien évidemment oui
les médecins doivent être à la
gouvernance du système de soins français
en collaboration avec des administratifs
moi je suis pas un administratif ya
probablement des choses que je ne sais
pas mais ce que je sais que certitude
c'est quand il a fallu sauver les
français en mars en france ça s'est bien
passé parce que les médecins s'en sont
occupés et personne d'autre et quand moi
j'ai interrogé mon ars elle était multi
qu alors je répète quand j'interroge
aimons rsl et et mutique et c'est parce
que le bon sens des médecins le bon sens
des soignants s'est mis en branle qu'on
a organisé les choses en mars mais la
moindre des choses ça aurait été en
tirer des conclusions
même des bonnes choses et de toutes les
mauvaises choses aussi et même les
bonnes choses il aurait fallu les
organiser pour qu'elle soit appliquée
dès septembre
il manque à cette santé en français ce
gouvernement un choc de bon sens voilà
c'est tout ce choc de bon sens sept
mille médecins à travers le monde ont
signé une tribune
il préconise la protection des plus
faibles et laisser les autres finalement
atteindre l'immunité collective
regardez et vous réagissez jean paul
hamon
les politiques actuelles de confinement
produisent des effets désastreux sur la
santé publique
à court moyen et long terme parmi les
conséquences
on peut citer entre autres une baisse
des taux de vaccination chez les enfants
une aggravation des cas de maladies
cardiovasculaires une baisse des examens
pour de possibles cancer ou encore une
détérioration de la santé mentale en
général cela va engendrer de grands
excès de mortalité dans les années à
venir
notamment dans la classe ouvrière est
parmi les plus jeunes
alors jean paul hamon si l'hôpital n'est
plus en mesure d'assurer sa mission
faute d'effectifs et de moyens
est ce que c'est une stratégie qui
devrait être mis sur la table selon vous
a écouté je peux en parler puisque j'ai
j'avais même proposé ça en mars de
mettre les personnes fragiles à l'abri
de les mettre vraiment à l'abri et de
laisser courir le virus heureusement
qu'on l'a pas fait parce que c'est ce
qui a été fait en suède et en suède
malgré une population particulièrement
disciplinés et qui respectent les
mesures barrières
c'est eux qui ont eu le taux de mort le
plus important parmi les pays nordiques
et clairement si on avait fait ça
l'hôpital qui a été au bord de la
rupture complète au board de choisir les
patients qu'ils allaient soigner parce
qu'il y avait plus de places en
réanimation au moment du confinement la
l'hôpital aurait été absolument
dé-bor-dée donc effectivement c'est
tentant de laisser courir
l'épidémie est de protéger les personnes
fragiles mais je peux vous dire que pour
ça il faudrait avoir un système
hospitalier avec avec des réalisations
et on prend un grand risque sur le plan
sur le plan des morts non ce qu'il faut
c'est c'est eh c'est ce qui a été fait
c'est à dire que tester tester isolé
mais mais seulement pour tester
effectivement depuis le mois de
septembre ça commence seulement à
s'arranger
ces derniers jours mais il a fallu
attendre des fois dix jours pour avoir
un test avec des gens qui se détester et
trois fois la semaine sans problème
parce que bon il avait décidé de le
faire et pix était open bars dans les
bars dans les enquêtes dans les open
bars parler dans les laboratoires donc
si vous voulez là il ya eu un système
qui était complètement déconnant ce
qu'il faut c'est avoir les tests
rapidement de façon à voir les résultats
des tests rapidement y compris à voir
les tests antigénique rapide qu'on peut
avoir 15 20 minutes lasser c'est dans
nos cabinets qu'il est faux de façon à
ce qu'on puisse isoler les gens qu'on
puisse distinguer la co vite de la
grille peut éventuellement du vrs pour
décider d'une stratégie met rapidement
en isolant les personnes handi
densifiant déco contact et en confinant
les gens voilà ce qu'il faudrait faire
seulement pour ça il faudrait qu'on
dispose de test dans nos cabinets que
les laboratoires qui commence à rendre
des résultats en 24-48 heures 30
vraiment les résultats dans les 12 24
heures pour
qu'on puisse agir rapidement c'est ça
qu'il faudrait seulement on savait que
c'est ce virus continue de circuler cet
été on voyait bien que dès qu'il y avait
un écart je pense aux clusters qui a eu
dans le bar de quiberon ou le type avait
transformé son bas rhin boîte de nuit il
y avait trois positifs pour se retrouver
avec 54 positif en une nuit
donc on savait que ce virus allait
recommencer à circuler à partir du
moment où l'école allait reprendre le
travail allait reprendre et les
transports allait reprendre
donc tout ça on le savait donc on
pouvait anticiper et permettre aux
laboratoires d'analysés d'acheter
suffisamment de machines pour qu'on
puisse produire les tests rapidement et
ne pas se retrouver quand même on est
quand même quasiment à la mi octobre
ça redémarre et depuis mois de septembre
ça continue d'augmenter doucement on
sait mieux traiter les gens en
réanimation
peut-être qu'ils vont rester moins
longtemps en réanimation et que le
système pourra tenir mais on en n'est
absolument pas sûr puisque la
actuellement on est en train on commence
déjà reporté d'eads et des opérations
qui étaient prévus pour libérer des lits
en réanimation
donc si vous voulez tout ça un peu
d'anticipation n'aurait pas de lui et
puis un peu de compétences aussi merci à
tous les trois pour votre décryptage
merci à vous alexis poulain rappelle que
vous êtes éditorialistes merci à vous
jean paul hamon un médecin généraliste
président d'honneur fédération des
médecins de france
merci également à vous arnaud chiche
anesthésistes fondateur du collectif
santé en danger et dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur la prise
de parole de la chef de file de
l'opposition biélorusse vet la natir
anoska ya et elle était invité ce
mercredi par la commission des affaires
étrangères à l'assemblée nationale
et puis nous parlerons du flou qui
persiste autour de la libération sophie
petro d'un otage au mali espérer libri
hier son sort reste incertain
[Musique]
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement à
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et et la préparer
il ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire entraîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter 20 à 30% de son
pub pour essayer pas tellement de
relancer son économie mais vraiment de
reconstruire un modèle est cette fois ci
nous n'avons plus droit à l'erreur nous
expliqué qu'effectivement le réveil va
être compliqué il va être douloureux il
ya eu un moment de très grand
relâchement et nous sommes en train de
payer ce moment de très grand
relâchement
donc c'est bien parce qu'on a échoué
dans la gestion de l'épidémie
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train d'échouer
dans la relance
le secteur de l'immobilier a n'a pas été
épargnés par les mesures sanitaires
d'urgence mis en place par le
gouvernement les banques aujourd'hui
donc quand on sait qu'elles vont un peu
coupé les robinets et si l couplé
robinet ça va être un petit peu plus
compliqué pour l'immobilier l'immobilier
haut de gamme était la valeur refuge par
excellence c'est le cas qui a plus de 75
ans a priori l'achète pas un appartement
il le veut et comme il aura pas beaucoup
de retraite
il est assez probable qu'ils soient
obligés de vendre son actif pour
continuer à vivre
il ya un vieillissement de la population
qui fait que vous allez avoir une baisse
des prix dit aujourd'hui que c'est la
revente des campagnes contre les villes
parce que les villes souffrent
globalement tout le marché comme dit
olivier va devenir plus raisonnable les
acquéreurs vont être plus sélectifs
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française
svetlana tirano sky à hier avec angela
merkel ce matin face aux députés
français objectif affiché de l'opposante
biélorusse convaincre les européens de
faire pression sur le président
alexandre loukachenko
le point avec notre reporter basse m
shelly depuis l'assemblée nationale à
paris c'est une audition qui aura duré
près de 1h30 celle de la nature à 9 scan
à cette opposante biélorusse devant les
membres de la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'assemblée nationale
une audition depuis berlin où elle
appelle les pays européens à soutenir
les opposants biélorusses face au
mouvement en place et face au
gouvernement et la politique du
président loukachenko
elle a été présentée comme la voix est
comme le visage de l'opposition
biélorusse et remercie les français
d'être aux côtés des biélorusses vous
propose d'écouter un extrait de cette
audition
la biélorussie est un exemple pour le
monde et j'ai eu l'honneur de devenir le
symbole de ce poste le biélorussie et je
voudrais encore une fois souligner que
dans notre lutte
il n'y a pas la place à la géopolitique
nous luttons pour le droit du peuple
biélorusse d'avoir des élections libres
et équitables et pour nos droits de
citoyen
donc notre lutte et pro biélorussie pour
nous a le soutien du peuple français est
très important il faut que tout le monde
on fasse pression sur le régime de
loukachenko
les sanctions c'est très important mais
ce n'est pas assez il faut absolument
arrêter tout soutien au régime
les élèves venus en lituanie depuis les
élections du 9 août dernier
la figure de l'opposition au bélarus en
appelle à l'union européenne pour
venir la biélorussie et continuer les
sanctions contre le pouvoir de
loukachenko le président actuel de la
biélorussie qui lui de son côté
dénoncent une ingérence européenne dans
les affaires de son pays emmanuel macron
a déclaré qu'il fallait continuer dans
la voie des négociations avec la vielle
russie afin de sortir de cette crise
politique que connaît le pays depuis les
élections du 9 août dernier il selon le
ministère russe de l'intérieur et les
agences russes svetlana tirano sky à
figurent dans la base de données des
personnes recherchées par moscou pour
une infraction au code pénal
un peu plus tôt dans la journée le
porte-parole de la présidence russe
s'exprimait sur le cas de l'opposante
biélorusse écouter elle reste sur le
territoire de l'union européenne et le
voyage activement à travers les pays
elle rencontre différents chefs d'état
et de gouvernement qui à leurs tours
considèrent comme illégitime
l'actuel chef d'état de la biélorussie
c'est à dire que la situation est
complètement différente
aucun contact n'est prévu
[Musique]
comme dans le cas de la biélorussie nous
ne voulons en aucun cas nous immiscer
dans les processus internes du
kirghizstan comme dans le cas de la
biélorussie je veux attirer votre
attention sur les propos du président il
existe de nombreux plans de coopération
entre la russie et le kirghizstan entre
la russie et la biélorussie la russie va
poursuivre cette coopération car les
nécessaires aux peuples des deux pays et
continuera à fournir l'assistance
nécessaire au kirghizstan et à la
biélorussie il s'agit des peuples des
deux pays
alors peut-on parler d'ingérence dans le
dossier biélorusse de la part de
bruxelles paris et berlin avec cette
tournée diplomatique de svetlana tirs à
9 callas et bien oui selon karine berger
glove qu elle est professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou
elle s'exprimait ce matin sur notre
antenne écouter ce qui est assez
surprenant quand même c'est tous ces
grands libéraux démocrates et cetera qui
agissent de l'étranger et qui demande
prend les sanctions économiques contre
le peuple du pays qui sont censé aimer
et défendre de toute la rame de tout
leur coeur en quelque sorte en sanction
du fait que ces gens mal élevée n'ait
pas voté pour ça pose quand même un
certain nombre de questions sur les
motivations derrière
surtout lorsque l'on sait que c'est la
nati fans parce qu'elle est accompagnée
par farhan haq ya turquie et en se
disant journalistes biélorusses qui
travaille pour radio liberty financé par
les etats unis et qui de 2016 et 2018 ce
conseiller a été formé dans les
universités américaines
donc oui il ya une forme d'ingérence
directe sur toute l'union européenne
aussi parler de financement de à de
l'opposition sous couvert dead habité
contre grands navires us n'ont pas très
bien maintenant et pour revenir sur la
venue à paris de l'opposante biélorusse
nous sommes avec l'autre blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales de
claude blanchemaison bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors qu'est ce que vous retenez du
discours en ligne de svetlana tirs à 9
ce qu'aia devant l'assemblée nationale
ben je crois d'abord qu'on veut dire que
ça sur l'intervention près près bien
préparées à l'avancé et surtout les
réponses qu'elle a faite aux différents
députés de la commission les affaires
étrangères montrent qu'elles étaient
sérieuses
articulé voire même déterminé alors elle
a indiqué que l'objectif c'était
d'obtenir de nouvelles élections en
biélorussie mais des élections libres et
équitables et elle a articulé 3-3-3
manière dans sa stratégie
d'abord il faut il faut effectivement
négocié avec le système at elle dit dans
son esprit pour écarter monsieur le cas
de gecko et ensuite avoir des élections
plus tard alors monsieur loukachenko
aujourd'hui a confirmé semble-t-il qu'il
était disposé à revoir la constitution
toute la question sera de savoir avec
qui discutera de ses révisions
constitutionnelles
madame d'ikanos kaya a par ailleurs
répondu aux questions plus posé les
députés et notamment quand ils lui ont
demandé comment peut-on vous aider elle
a répondu de manière assez précise
elle à dire d'abord en faisant des
voyages en biélorussie que les députés
français européens viennent voir par
eux-mêmes
quelle est la situation et on voit mal
que le gouvernement biélorusse puisse
s'y opposer
et puis elle a proposé des choses très
concrètes
elle a dit par exemple que la pologne
avait commencé à prodiguer des veines
médicale aux gens qui étaient arrêtés et
elle a parlé de corridors humanitaires
pour ces aides médicales qui pourraient
être amplifiées de la part des pays de
l'union européenne elle a aussi parlé de
l'accueil des étudiants étudiants dont
certains ont été renvoyés de leur
université parce qu'ils manifestaient et
effectivement dans ce cas là pourrait-il
être accueillis dans des universités de
pays de l'union européenne elle a aussi
parlé de fonds de solidarité pour venir
en aide aux prisonniers politiques ou à
leur famille ou pour venir en aide à des
employés qui auraient été licenciés par
les entreprises publiques qui commençait
représente à peu près 75 % de l'économie
biélorusse donc pour une fois elle était
assez concrète dans ses propositions
et effectivement elle a reçu un accueil
plutôt sympathique de la part de ses
députés de la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'assemblée nationale
alors pourquoi aujourd'hui l'opposant de
biélorusses at-elle l'oreille de paris
et de berlin au parce qu'elle représente
l'image de la la liberté la liberté
d'expression de la liberté de
manifestation
des droits de l'homme des élections
libres et que dans des pays comme
l'allemagne comme la france s'il ya un
écho dans les médias et dans la
population en plus du côté français ça
fait peut-être penser au tableau de
delacroix la liberté guidant le peuple
enfin c'est une autre époque et d'autres
circonstances bien sûr mais c'est vrai
qu'elle a cette image et que en plus
c'est un combat de femmes puisque ce
sont magnifiques majoritairement des
femmes qui manifestent et notamment le
samedi il ya une manifestation de femmes
dans les grandes villes deviennent
russie donc tous ces éléments font que
effectivement il y a un regard
bienveillant de la part des populations
en allemagne et en france
alors le président alexandre loukachenko
doit-il la craindre
ils essaient l'ignorer ils essaient
l'ignorait mais c'est compliqué parce
qu'il ne peut pas complètement ignoré
les manifestants on ignorait
complètement les sanctions d'ailleurs
madame tikhonov kaya a demandé un nom un
allongement de la liste des individus se
met à sanction incidemment elle est
toujours hostile à des sanctions
économiques donc il n'y a pas de
sanctions économiques et il n'y aura pas
de sanction économique car effectivement
elle s'appliquerait plus tôt à la
population qu'aux dirigeants la
biélorussie sur des sanctions
personnelles
donc je pense que monsieur loukachenko
est relativement tranquille dans la
mesure où ils contrôlent parfaitement
ses organes de sécurité police et armée
qui a pratiquement pas de défection et
qu' il peut aussi contrôler par le biais
des entreprises publiques
lazare où les ouvriers qui avaient
commencé à se mettre en grève
il y a quelques semaines donc il n'a pas
à être inquiet à court terme
simplement on voit aussi que lorsqu'ils
étaient reçus par monsieur poutine
monsieur poutine lui a dit aux fêtes et
la réforme de la constitution dont vous
aviez parlé
il y a quelques semaines c'est pour
quand et c'est pour ça qu'il a repris
cette idée aujourd'hui monsieur
loukachenko il se sent donc obligés de
faire quelque chose il ne peut pas ne
rien faire et ce quelque chose c'est
probablement en effet dans son esprit
une réforme de la constitution qui peut
être libre à livrer un peu les
institutions et donnerait plus de
pouvoir à son gouvernement qui
permettrait aussi de faire des élections
libres simplement là il ya un petit
problème qui est que madame chicanos
callas ne veut pas discuter de la
constitution avec monsieur loukachenko
et qu'il faudra sans doute trouver un
arrangement
on notera que les sanctions européennes
et sanctions individuelles ne touchent
pas monsieur cochet co personnellement
puisque monsieur macron considère il y a
encore des marges de négociation et je
pense que madame merkel le pense aussi
avec l'ouest et e il est sans doute
possible de discuter autre monsieur
loukachenko et l'opposition de la
conduite et des conditions dans
lesquelles la constitution pourrait être
révisée et des conditions dans
lesquelles des élections pourraient être
organisée à terme dans des conditions
acceptables par tout le monde
donc monsieur loukachenko est condamné à
vivre de façon un peu un commode avec
cette opposition un peu bruyante
peut-être pas directement avec madame
petit canot sky à puisque elle est à
l'étranger et qu'il est probable que il
laissera pas rentré de sitôt en
biélorussie merci beaucoup
claude blanchemaison je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en relations
internationales
l affaire alexeï navalni maintenant avec
un nouveau rebondissement la russie par
la voix de maria sakharova a dénoncé des
accusations inacceptables
une réaction de la russie attendue après
que berlin et paris est pointé du doigt
une implication et une responsabilité
russe l'allemagne qui exige des
explications de moscou sur
l'empoisonnement présumé de l'opposant
sous peine de sanction des mesures
restrictives jeu sites ciblés et
proportionnée france et allemagne vont
transmettre à leurs partenaires
européens des propositions de sanctions
supplémentaires
ces propositions viseront les personnes
jugées responsables de ce crime et de la
violation des normes internationales
ainsi qu'une entité participant au
programme nos vies chuck et on en vient
la situation de sophie petrona et pas de
nouvelles avancées dans la libération de
la dernière otage française dans le
monde son fils a notamment déclaré être
sans nouvelles de sa mère hier sa
famille avait pourtant laissé entendre
que son transfert était en cours
l'humanitaire de 75 ans avait été
enlevée en 2016 à gao au nord du mali du
côté du gouvernement français en reste
prudent sur la situation regarder je me
garderais d'avoir tout propos dans ce
contexte dans des heures et des jours
qui peuvent être parfois cruciaux je ne
veux pas interférer dans cette situation
c'est un sujet comme toutes les
questions d'otages extrêmement sensible
et pour lequel souvent beaucoup de
choses doivent se jouer dans la plus
grande discrétion
une situation tendue au mali une
vingtaine de personnes ont été enlevées
par des hommes armés
dans le secteur de niono centre du pays
neuf de ces villageois serait toujours
retenus les autres auraient été relâchés
selon le chef du village
un jeune villageois a été tué pendant
l'enlèvement at-il ajouté et autres
attaques toujours au centre du pays
celle contre des soldats de la garde
nationale malienne
leur convoi a été la cible d'assaillants
non identifiés
trois militaires ont perdu la vie c'est
donc dans ce contexte de tension que le
flou persiste autour de l'éventuelle
libération de sophie et rona pour en
parler nous sommes avec mériadec raffray
il est journaliste spécialiste des
questions de défense
secrétaire général de l'association des
journalistes de défense mériadec raffray
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors malgré plusieurs
déclarations politiques hier soir aucune
officialisation de la part du
gouvernement français ou maliens sur une
libération de ce fip et rona est ce que
cela est inquiétant
bonsoir olivier tout d'abord c'est une
affaire compliquée et on voit bien que
ces derniers 24 heures il y avait
plusieurs rebondissements certains
annoncé la libération de sophie petrona
dont évidemment on se réjouirait je
rappelle qu'elle a 75 ans qu'elle est en
des temps détenu depuis le 24 décembre
2005 précisément donc certains
l'annonçaient on voit bien que c'est
compliqué je pense que des prêts paris
exerce évidemment des pressions
importantes puisque les la communication
djihadiste est à dire et demi s'est elle
aussi mise en branle à l'annoncé au près
de 200 djihadistes libéré en
contrepartie de la libération se fit
patronat et de soumaïla cissé je vous
rappelle aussi qu'il est otage l'ancien
premier ministre
en tout cas ce que moi je note c'est que
dans cette affaire à nouveau pari est en
réaction et non pas en anticipation sent
bien que paris n'est pas dans le coup
paris subit je vous rappelle que début
août les coups il ya eu un coup d'état
militaire et tous les experts sont
d'accord pour dire que paris n'a rien vu
venir non plus c'est inquiétant de ce
point de vue là et enfin si on extrapole
ce qui pourrait se passer on extrapole
une libération de ce filtre petronas
c'est évidemment un point bon point pour
le gouvernement qui de cette manière
marque son territoire reprend prend
prend toute sa dimension en jouant cette
carte on peut aussi voir l'autre côté de
la carte à savoir qu'ils vont passer un
accord avec le fameux djihadistes qaïda
ghali qui est l'homme cible numéro un
des français c'est lui qui en avril
dernier a ouvert officiellement un canal
de négociation avec bamako pour
l'instant il ne s'est rien passé
mais évidemment c'était une très
mauvaise nouvelle pour les français
c'est une presque une prise à revers ou
un âne et un échec ce serait un échec
stratégique pour les français parce que
justement paris qui subit alors qu'ils
négocient directement avec les preneurs
d'otages est ce que vous avez des
informations à ce sujet là non j'ai pas
d'informations et ces voix là c'est pour
l'instant c'est compliqué il y avait il
ya sans doute plusieurs canaux ouvert
des canaux officiels ou officieux mais
c'est plutôt du mali où ça serait plutôt
le mali où la france finalement alors je
vais ça me paraît assez évident que le
mali et en étant en pôle position la
france j'espère en tout cas juin rôle il
ya un pays dont on peut parler aussi
olivier qui me paraît important à
souligner c'est l'algérie les experts
savent bien que s'ils y à dagahaley est
a miraculeusement échappé à la cible de
nos forces spéciales en particulier
c'est parce qu'il est protégé de
notoriété publique par l'algérie
l'algérie n'a jamais accepté le dit pas
mais l'algérie n'a jamais accepté que la
france revienne jouer dans son
arrière-cour stratégique dans son pré
carré c'est à dire au mali en
particulier au nord donc sans doute que
l'algérie est également à la manoeuvre
et je pense que l'algérie serait très
heureuse de marquer ce point dans le dos
des français donc c'est aussi évidemment
un facteur qui est pas terrible pour les
français mais surtout
olive et si vous permettez cela aurait
deux conséquences pour la france d'une
part ça va la forcer à accélérer les ses
rayons stratégiques
7 évidemment pour la france une mauvaise
nouvelle pour le récit qu'elle nous sert
depuis des années dans cette fameuse
guerre de sept ans cette guerre du sel
de sept ans on nous explique que la
france est là pour casser les reins des
jihadistes pendant que l'état malien et
des politiques maliens se remettre en
selle
on voit bien que les choses sont
beaucoup plus compliquées ça c'est la
première chose est sûre le plan
opérationnel évidemment imaginer si des
dizaines de jl djihadistes était
officiellement libéré selon à cela
serait un très mauvais signal envoyé à
nos militaires qui se battent
je vous le rappelle pour rétablir la
confiance c'est quoi c'est pour gagner
le coeur des populations pour dire aux
populations qui sont toujours les otages
de ces guerres entre hétéros 2-2 contre
le terrorisme pour leur dire
elles se battent pour leur dire soyez
avec nous nous représentons la force
légitime et d'état malien et la paix or
la libération de ces djihadistes sera
évidemment le pain le signal contraire
envoyée à toutes ces populations qui
sont toujours les otages de ces de ces
guerres et je vous rappelle que les
djihadistes évidemment se noie se cache
dans la population pour pouvoir exister
enfin dernier point cette si cette
libération intervenait avec ses
contreparties c'est à dire c'est ces
libérations de djihadistes ce serait
évidemment une victoire pour les
djihadistes la guerre antiterroriste est
une 1ère frottement de volonté comme
disent les militaires et en plus que les
djihadistes ont le temps pour eux ce que
les démocraties occidentales
non pas vraiment justement pour éviter
un tel scénario est ce que la france
pourrait payer une rançon par exemple on
sait qu officiellement ça ne se fait pas
mais est ce que ça peut être une
solution justement pour éviter ce
scénario
alors effectivement officiellement les
états la france ne paye pas de rançon
on sait très bien les spécialistes
savaient bien qu'on ne libère pas un
otage et c'est le dernier otage français
détenu dans le monde
une femme de 75 ans à fort pouvoir
symbolique émotionnel auprès de nos
populations
on sait très bien tous très bien que ce
type de libération exige toujours des
contreparties qu'elle est en général
elles sont souvent indirects voilà c'est
n'y a pas officiellement effectivement
il n'y a pas forcément de comme on
dirait juste d'intervention directe de
l'état français mais il ya souvent des
contreparties indirects en tout cas
cette libération est ce que pourrait
donner plus de crédibilité à la junte ou
au gouvernement de transition en place
au mali ils ont quelque chose à tirer un
aussi dans ce dossier oui c'est ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure au
préambule rapidement c'est évident que
si le jeune pouvoir en place le
gouvernement de banda aux marques ce
point c'était crucial pour établir sa
stature dans cette dans ces régions où
la discussion le bal arbres les
dialogues sont importants sa marque
aurait évidemment leur capacité à
dialoguer ce sont des militaires mais
dont qu'ils auraient cette capacité à
dialoguer y compris avec l'ensemble des
partis il y a eu déjà de l'or des
différentes guerres entre le nord et le
sud
depuis les années 60 plusieurs accords
qui ont été que conclut comme cela c'est
là qu'on s'est mis autour d'une table ou
dans le désert en tout cas et on a
dialogué donc c'est dans le c'est dans
les gènes de cette région et puis et
puis alors cela voudrait dire en même
temps que la paix serait faite sur le
dos enfin serez fait avec les
djihadistes avec le premier d'entre eux
le plus ancien il ya la galerie et ça
pour le coup c'est une alors c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour le gouvernement
malien mais c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour la région
cela supposerait que un état
officiellement passe un pacte avec ceux
qui aujourd'hui ils sont présentés par
l'ensemble des experts comme les
principaux terroristes- régionaux à
grand merci mais avec raffray pour votre
éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des questions de
défense
secrétaire général de l'association des
journalistes de défense est resté avec
nous sur rt france dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la situation
sanitaire sous haute tension en bois de
l'eau
l'activité hospitalière il est très
intense notamment avec des seniors
particulièrement touché par la forme
grave du comité 19
et puis nous nous arrêterons sur l'étude
discovery ce vaste essai clinique
européen pour évaluer quatre traitements
expérimentaux contre le président 19
suscite interrogations et
incompréhension a tout de suite sur rt
france dans un peu moins de dix minutes
maintenant
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité dans des tas d'ordures âge
les prix malheureusement lui jugé amadou
gon coulibaly est décédé pourquoi
aujourd'hui le président et candidat à
sa propre succession
nous estimons que l'opposant ouattara
est celui qui a le leadership nécessaire
pour faire face ont pu fiction posent à
nous tant au niveau interne ou externe
un climat particulier en ce moment en
côte d'ivoire des violences sous
prétexte donc manifestation et
d'expression du droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on est si m est-ce
que sincèrement vous êtes certains que
le scrutin du 31 octobre sera maintenu à
la date prévue
il n'y a pas de raison que ce scrutin ne
soit pas maintenu
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collectés vous
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
dignité gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment on devient jean louis etienne
parce que vous êtes un héros pour plein
d'enfants je rêvais de faire des
expéditions se trouve savoir ce que
c'était et l'arrivée au pôle nord
quelques années après je me souviens
très bien du moment où je me suis dit
mais ça ça va être mal ce parcours là
vous a placé dans la bataille écologique
le réchauffement climatique est une
réalité quand on voit bien à la 37
cantona un degré de plus de 38 en
médecine robles à une fabrique une
petite fièvre gouffre quelque chose la
plage est l année là aujourd'hui chacun
dans ses activités impact la nature
impacte notre question environnementale
le risque c'est évidemment le
réchauffement climatique
mais l'autre risque c'est aussi la
réduction de l'activité économique
jean jaurès disait une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup aller à l'idéal
tout en comprenant le réel
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
sécheresse mauvaises récoltes canicule
il y avait beaucoup de bétail avant
aujourd'hui il est impossible d'avoir
des animaux
rien ne pousse ici que mangerait les
animaux le climat de la terre est
aujourd'hui plus chaud qui ne l'a été au
cours des cent mille dernières années
[Musique]
pas d'eau pour la maison pas d'eau pour
cela vaut à la fin du siècle
il fera encore plus chaud
le moment est venu de réfléchir à la
façon dont gérer les conséquences
comment nous sauver cela entraînera
d'importants bouleversements à quel
impact faut-il s'attendre
sauront-ils visible dans l'environnement
l'économie et la politique
personne ne le sait trois listes
[Musique]
haifa j'ai entendu parler de wikileaks
et de julian assange pour la première
fois quand j'ai vu les images filmées
depuis l'hélicoptère en irak
je pense qu'il ya des gens dans l'armée
américaine qui ne lui ont jamais
pardonné
je ne suis pas pour la peine de mort et
puisque je ne suis pas pour la peine de
mort il n'a qu'une chose à faire abattre
ce fils de qui légalement c'est est
historique il n'est pas d'avoir un
journaliste indépendant
un type avec son ordinateur révélant des
crimes de guerre un large public
l'idée de développer une boîte de dépôts
numériques anonymes ont un lien avec le
média qu'est wikileaks
c'est une vraie nouveauté mais je
n'avais pas prévu qu'il deviendra
célèbre dans le monde entier si vite
qu'il serait à la tête de l'une des plus
puissantes organisations médiatiques du
monde h
il avait beaucoup de jalousie dans
l'immédiat traditionnelle envers
wikileaks est en vert assange en
particulier pourquoi n'est-il pas plus
comme nous ils vont accuser d'étaler des
excréments sur les murs morose ce qui
est fou
et du orléans julian assange est à l'
isolement dans une prison de haute
sécurité attendant peut-être une
sentence d'emprisonnement à perpétuité
alors je ne veux pas le voir mourir dans
une prison américaine à l'infini et je
crois que c'est le sort qui l'attend
[Musique]
nous voulons transmettre aux enfants les
souvenir encore vif
ce ce qui est nous est arrivé nous qui
étions de jeunes prisonniers lors de la
grande guerre patriotique
la seconde guerre mondiale il tragédie
pour toute l'humanité
des chars la dévastation un obus des
explosions nous étions enfants ils
n'avions pas peur des morts nous avions
peur des allemands
c'est dur de revivre ça des millions de
victimes de vie anéantie
la fin car ce que percée des tirs aux
enfants qui pleurent rient les mères qui
pleurent mais bon je me souviens qu'un
jour alors que je marchais j'ai vu en
vieil homme allongé il était
probablement déjà mort déjà rigide un
petit garçon lui ramper dessus d'essayer
de le réveiller
jamais dans l'histoire la cruauté envers
les enfants n'avaient atteint cette
ampleur sur les taux raconter bien nous
avons su avec 18 millions de personnes
sont passées par 14000 camps de
concentration ghetto et prison 2 5
millions d'enfants sont morts
il est revenu ici des décennies plus
tard après tout il aurait pu ne jamais
revoir tout cela briansk sa ville natale
la guerre
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 7 octobre 2020
le personnel soignant toujours en
première ligne face à un regain de
l'épidémie et la colère ne retombe pas
alors que les promesses du ségur de la
santé tarde à se concrétiser
emmanuel macron la sueur est encore hier
en visite à l'hôpital rothschild à paris
je ne veux pas laisser tomber l'hôpital
le président qui a précisé tout à
l'heure qu'il faut plus de restrictions
là où le circule le virus circule trop
vite à la veille d'un nouveau point
hebdomadaire d'olivier ferrand aux etats
unis la campagne poursuit son cours
à moins d'un mois de la présidentielle
place ce soir au débat des colistiers à
salt lake city entre la démocrate kamala
harris et le vice-président républicain
mike pence
si donald trump qui n'a plus de
symptômes depuis 24 heures est impatient
de croiser le fer avec joe biden le 15
octobre
ce dernier appelle lui à la prudence
[Musique]
le haut karabagh selon le ministère
azerbaïdjanais
une réunion de médiation internationale
se tiendra ce jeudi à genève le conflit
armé lui s'étend et prend des
proportions de plus en plus importante
est la capitale du territoire a été
bombardé cette nuit
l'arménie accuse la turquie je cite
d'avoir provoqué la guerre n'a la france
elles affirment qu'ankara est impliquée
militairement dans le conflit alors
qu'elle diplomatie mettre en oeuvre pour
sortir de ce conflit ce sera l'objet de
notre face à face
[Musique]
et on débute avec la situation sanitaire
en france et les derniers chiffres de
santé publique france à l'agent
s'annonce 18 1746 nouvelles
contaminations kovy de 19 ans 24 heures
80 personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital
le taux de positivité des tests
s'établit lui à 9,1 pour cent
le président emmanuel macron qui a
précisé tout à l'heure lors d'un
entretien sur tf1 et france 2 qu'il faut
plus de restrictions là où le virus
circule trop 8es avec ses 20 décès liés
au courant d'un virus la semaine
dernière à la guadeloupe connaît un
nouveau record pourtant cette semaine
les indicateurs de l'épidémie diminuait
avec 734 cas recensés et le territoire
et est passé en alerte maximale le 23
septembre à mai les hôpitaux signale
tout de même une activité intense et des
seniors touchés par des formes graves de
la maladie comme à marseille ou encore à
paris la guadeloupe a elle aussi pris
des mesures restrictives
jusqu'au 13 octobre selon la préfecture
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe bélair secrétaire général de la
fédération santé de la cgt guadeloupe
philippe bélair merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors on disait
20 personnes décédées ducobu 19 la
semaine dernière 35 personnes
actuellement en réanimation
la situation est elle très inquiétante
selon vous les plus inquiétantes dans la
mesure où je vous rappelle que depuis
l'an dernier nous avions fait un
mouvement social où les jeunes
dénoncions le manque de moyens puisque
nous n'aurons pas autant les deux
événements nous savions que nous savons
toujours d'ailleurs comme sont dans un
pays x à fort risque
nous ne savions même pas que le cette
affaire de kovy d'arrivée mais déjà en
tant que pays à hauts risques avec des
tremblements de terre avec la d'autres
épidémies connaissant qui d'ailleurs
nous sommes en période heure de la
mecque
nous avons le récit pionner que le
risque volcanique et nous avions dénoncé
déjà le moc de matériaux d'aujourd'hui
nous faisons face à en pratiquer
véritablement pratique à ce que nous
craignons l'an dernier et voilà la
situation elle sans pino non seulement
parce qu'effectivement il y a des cas de
cockpit mais il ya aussi un véritable
problème de moyens de personnel
justement quels sont les moyens
matériels et humains qu'il vous manque
aujourd'hui
alors c'est pas particulièrement des
soignants particulier aux mains du
matériel de soin particulièrement
content qu'on arrête les restrictions
budgétaires
parce qu'aujourd'hui on nous parle de
mutualisation de moyens mais en fait
c'est de la concentration de moyens et
c'est là le drame la guadeloupe n'est
pas seule dans le cas où tous les
hôpitaux de france et de navarre sont
dans ce cas là même nous
particulièrement et je pense aussi pour
la martinique
c'est aussi le cas ce sont des zones à
haut risque où il faut véritablement que
les autorités sanitaires et un autre
déroulement de pensée par rapport à nos
problématiques insulaires
alors quelles sont les populations les
plus touchées aujourd'hui
alors effectivement nous avons un gros
problème de comorbidité puisque nous
sommes aussi dans une population déjà
qui vieillit énormément en plus de ça et
à d'autres pathologies est du genre
diabète pathologie des gens quand ce
cancer successifs d'ailleurs a notamment
à tous les empoisonnements thériault que
nous avons subies avec la chlordécone
dans d'autres cas pathologique à 13
écuries nous avons une maladie
particulière s'il arrive en aussitôt ce
qui affecte aussi les des voies
respiratoires
en cas de crise donc nous avons une
population déjà fragilisée et en plus
avec les risques
nous avons tous véritablement tout nous
l'avions prévu encore une fois les
autorités sanitaires et politiques n'ont
pas voulu écouter parce qu'ils sont dans
une logique libérale logique le
réception budgétaire et voilages pareil
alors dû du coup pour vous comment
est-ce qu'il faut appréhender la
situation aujourd'hui on sait que treize
militaires ont été envoyés pour prêter
main forte
déjà quel est leur rôle sur place et
qu'est ce qui vous manque
comment articuler finalement cette lutte
contre l'épidémie sur l'île selon vous
écoutez je vais vous le dire tout le
problème est dans le financement le bon
financement bien fléché avec le matériel
les moyens humains des moyens financiers
les moyens matériels qu'il faut c'est ça
le problème c'est que au fond on a
concentré tous les moyens nous avons
douze hôpitaux tous les moyens quasiment
sur le seul chu de lille
certes mais le problème c'est que le chu
et est en grande difficulté et voire
même en difficulté financière d'ailleurs
mais aussi en quantifie culte et
fonctionnelle le chu ne peux pas
répondre à ça
le chu ne peux pas répondre ils sont
bien ils ont beau faire plan b un plan
blanc pardon ce plan blanc ne répond
même difficilement
à la crise sanitaire tout simplement
parce que les choses ont été mal pensée
très très mal pensée et la réaction par
rapport à cette pandémie dès le départ
n'a pas été la bonne
en tout cas votre sens alors les restos
restent ouverts les salles de sport
également est ce que il faudrait prendre
des mesures plus drastiques selon vous
justement pour faire face à cette
épidémie
ou alors il ya effectivement une
situation économique qui est elle aussi
est en crise sur place oui il ya une
situation économique déjà avant la crise
salutaire il y avait déjà une cuisse à
et que nous mais que pat en théorie qu
attend dans ce pays mais la crise
sanitaire va accélérer les choses il
était honnête que l'économie va va en
pâtir d'ici deux ou trois mois
ceci dit les restaurateurs pour répondre
précisément à votre question on était au
tribunal administratif
le restaurateur et les salles de sport
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils ont la
possibilité aujourd'hui parce que là le
tribune jean yves gain de cause devant
le tribunal administratif qui a demandé
au préfet de revoir de revoir son arrêté
préfectoral puisqu'au départ il était
convenu depuis dimanche soir que tout le
monde ferme basque rideau à 100%
aujourd'hui les choses seront mitigés ce
qui leur permet de d'avoir une réaction
sur le thème du marché économique autre
que ce qui était prévu par la préfecture
alors le président emmanuel macron veut
plus de restrictions il a annoncé ce
soir là où le virus circule trop vite il
faut plus de restrictions aujourd'hui en
boyau pour vous également écouter le
virus est là il faut qu'on sache que le
vieux sol et quand je dis ça je ne dis
pas qu'il ne faille pas point de ces
précautions il faut prendre ses
précautions mais le virus est là et le
vicieux là pour un moment il va falloir
faire avec
je lui ai déjà dit martelé sur d'autres
médias il va falloir qu'on apprenne à
faire avec
autrement vivre autrement vivre
peut-être avec beaucoup plus de
précautions mais nous avons l'impression
que le gouvernement en fait les
autorités aussi des politiques
sanitaires essaie de se rattraper par
rapport
coupé du début de la crise sanitaire
mais le virus est là et je crois que la
population l'a parfaitement compris la
population prend les précautions
nécessaires bien sûr il ya quelques
individus qui pointe
comment dirais-je des risques ces
quelques individualités ne sont pas la
généralité la grande majorité de la
population prend ses précautions
je peux vous l'assurer merci beaucoup
philippe bélair d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la fédération
santé de la cgt wever des chiffres
inquiétants alors que la recherche d'un
traitement est toujours en cours et que
le débat fait toujours rage autour de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine une polémique
est née sur la toile autour de l'étude
discovery qui a sorti cette molécule de
ces essais cliniques
c'est l'édito de guilmard aussi sur la
toile c'est un début d'indignation
depuis ce mardi des comptes twitter
relais un message de didier rahout ce
tweet dans lequel le professeur cite les
résultats préliminaires de l'étude
discovery des résultats qui selon lui
prouveraient que sa molécule fétiche
l'hydroxyde chloroquine serait bel et
bien efficace pour rappel hydroxy
chloroquine avait été sortie de l'étude
discovery à la suite d'un article
frauduleux du land sept avant d'être
réintégré une fois la fraude avérée pour
être définitivement abandonnée peu après
car jugées inefficaces injustement donc
selon didier rahout et depuis plane un
soupçon de délit d' injustice autour de
l'île d'anglesey chloroquine un
traitement peu onéreux que l'on
chercherait à enterrer par favoritisme
envers la big pharma problème des
données partielles concernant
l'hydroxyte eurokin avaient déjà été
publiés dans un autre tweet par nathan
piper smadja infectiologues interne à
l'ap-hp et qui lui prétend que l'étude
discovery démontre l'inefficacité de
l'hydroxyde croquer est-ce que vous avez
remarqué les deux tweets qui se
contredisent illustrent leurs propos à
l'aide de la même image des mêmes
chiffres rigoureusement si l'on en croit
donc l'interprétation de ces chiffres
par les deux infectiologues l'hydroxyde
chloroquine est à la fois efficace et
inefficace alors qui croire
la question ne se pose en fait régulière
au gré de la publication des études
scientifiques ici une étude italienne
qui démontre l'efficacité de la molécule
là une étude belge qui parvient aux
mêmes conclusions mais là une méta étude
qui prétend l' inverse
on ne sait plus quoi penser et ça tombe
bien c'est comme ça que la science
fonctionne sauf qu'on l'a oublié cela
fait sept mois que l'on dit à peu près
tout et son contraire sur l'hydroxyde
chloroquine com à propos de didier
rahout tour à tour mais si génial
victime du complot politico pharma tic
au parisien ou bien escrocs fer de lance
de la dissidence marseillaise uniquement
guidé par une quête de gloire
personnelle et bien entendu ce relais
dans les médias les partisans des deux
camps des invités plus ou moins
concernés et aussi il faut le dire plus
ou moins compétents parce que pour
appréhender les résultats d'une étude et
pour juger de sa crédibilité encore
faut-il savoir ce qu'est un protocole
d'essai clinique un essai randomisé un
groupe contrôle un test en double
aveugle en effet placebo ce que signifie
la pi value un odds ratio un rapport de
risque un risque relatif à un intervalle
de confiance et j'en passe vous ne
maîtrisez pas tous ces termes je vous
rassure la plupart de ceux qui
s'expriment tout de même sur le sujet
n'ont plus cette période de crise
sanitaire aura aussi été celle de
l'ultra crépy d'organismes un terme
savant récemment popularisé par etienne
klein qui désigne le fait de parler d'un
sujet pour lequel on n'a aucune
compétence nous nous jetons tous depuis
plus d'un semestre sur la moindre étude
portant sur l'hydroxyde chloroquine sur
le dernier article à propos de didier
rahout ou du coc vide 19 en oubliant que
notre compétence en la matière est loin
d'être suffisante pour alimenter
sainement tout débat scientifique car la
science a besoin de temps et de patience
pour avancer depuis sept mois il semble
que le temps scientifique et rejoint le
temps politique et médiatique
un temps qui ne permet pas à la science
d'exprimer un consensus et sans
consensus
la science devient un acte de foi et si
vous vous souvenez de giordano bruno et
de galilée foi et science font rarement
bon ménage
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe froguel maître de conférences
en génétique professeur à l'impérial
college de londres et à l'université de
lille philippe froguel
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france
alors finalement l'entendait à à
l'instant est ce que le noeud du
problème c'est pas que le temps
scientifique a rattrapé le temps
médiatique aujourd'hui c'est une partie
du problème ça c'était évident cela dit
c'est pas que ça c'est aussi parce que
la communauté scientifique et médicale
est extrêmement divisé une partie de mes
collègues font plus de politique que de
science
et effectivement les la méthodologie et
la façon de s'exprimer de didier raoult
n'ont pas vraiment facilité les choses
et ça entraînait des antagonismes
terrible très loin des débats
scientifiques habituelles alors contre
concernant cette fameuse étude discovery
pourquoi les résultats ne sont pas
publiés
discovery est un échec énorme qui a
coûté extrêmement cher à l'état français
donc aux contribuables aux 10 et 15
millions d'euros
les raisons en sont multiples d'abord
pour bien voir ça il faut comparer avec
l'étude
l'étude anglaise qui s'appelle recovery
qui a fait qui a inclus 13000 personnes
publié plusieurs articles scientifiques
étaient inquiètes un très grand succès
si on compare avec ça des études
françaises qui s'appelle discovery ses
850 personnes dont 50 noms français et
donc on n'a jamais eu ce qu'on appelle
la puissance statistique c'est à dire
assez de patients pour pouvoir répondre
à des questions portant sur des
médicaments qui sont pas extrêmement
extrêmement efficace au premier coup
d'oeil
et pour cela il faudrait avoir beaucoup
plus de patients qu'on n'a pas été
capable en france d'obtenir et pour pour
pourquoi pas été capables de les obtenir
ces 800 patients pour cette étude
alors pour un certain nombre de
personnes dont avant mon neveu le
célèbre nathan
force majeure qui est un garçon très
doué à qui est élève d'un des grands
mandarins de pétales bichat à paris
c'est par exemple à cause de didier
raoul et des parce que les patients ne
voulait pas entrer dans discovery vous
êtes tous être à l'hydroxyethyl ça peut
être joué un rôle je pense que c'est
surtout la la médiocrité de la recherche
médicale française hospitalière qui a
été totalement incapable de faire ce que
font les anglais c'est à dire des
disciplines et de faire des projets
simples beaucoup plus simple que ce qui
était discovery et puis d'un choeur tous
les patients sans se poser de questions
ça sans jouer les divas et si ça avait
été fait on aurait des réponses aux
questions de disque gai pourtant on a le
sentiment c'est vrai que la rue de la
recherche française
finalement est en tête dans le monde
c'est en tout cas chez les français on
se souvient d'un institut pasteur de
toutes les deux toutes les trouvailles
c'est plus le cas aujourd'hui regardez
le prix nobel aujourd'hui de madame
charpentier certes elle est française
mais elle s'est exilée en suède puis
ensuite en allemagne pour faire ses
études qui ont conduit au prix nobel
donc la recherche française nous reste
moi qui travaille à la fois en
angleterre et en france que je peux
comparer la recherche britannique
médicale en tout cas est bien en avance
par rapport à la recherche française
alors on en a parlé de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine son arrêt sur vous c'est une
décision politique et non scientifique
les différentes discussions sur les
faits de yorkshire qui n'en fait porte
sur des véhicules
si on regarde ton apparaît juste avant
dans votre sujet il ya un un effet à peu
près positif de 20 % d'amélioration
simplement comme à 10
discovery n'a pas inclus assez de
patience et c'était parce qu'on appelle
significatifs statistiquement les études
qui ont qui sont parus récemment y
compris certaines méta analyse montre
une efficacité devant diront 20% soit de
mortalité en moins soit 2 d'apparition
-2
que la maladie chez des gens qui ont été
contaminés rapport sans scientifiquement
c'est parce c'est pas négligeable
et moi je pense qu'il ya un petit effet
cela dit médicalement veut pas dire qu'
il faudrait traiter tout le monde parce
qu'il ya des effets secondaires parce
qu'on sait pas qu'il administrait et
donc sais c'est pas suffisant
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir revenir en
arrière à mon avis sur les toxiques la
rouquine même s'il ya à mon avis un
petit effet alors on constate aussi que
avec exactement les mêmes chiffres avec
exactement les hommes graphique
les lectures des scientifiques sont
différentes comment comprendre ça aussi
tout simplement l'effet est le même
c'est à peu près 20% de des différences
simplement si on prend cinq mille
patients on va voir suffisamment de
personnes pour avoir un test statistique
qui va être concluants alors que là avec
un tout petit nombre
on avait un test statistique qui ne
l'était pas mais c'était la même chose à
ces 20 % de différence tout ça montre
l'incapacité terrible de discovery
d'avoir assez de patio pour répondre à
toutes les questions qu'ils ont posées
et pour l'instant ils ont répondu à
aucune
alors aujourd'hui qu'en est il de la
recherche sur un traitement pour contrer
le vide 19
est ce que on sait s'il y a des
médicaments qui fonctionne mieux que
d'autres est ce que des études
finalement ont permis de trouver à armen
aujourd'hui il ya deux questions
différentes la première c'est de savoir
ce qui a été indiqué mans qui vont
diminuer la mortalité des gens
sévèrement atteints et là il y en a un
qui s'appelle la d'examen et à zone
c'est des corticoïdes
ça a été testé par les anglais et
parlait français ça s'est passé un
indicatif de la façon différente de
penser entre les entre les deux pays
en tout cas les deux communautés de
médical pour la france pourquoi la
france ne fait pas rêver les maisons
belfond c'est très simple les
réanimateurs français on dit oh bah
finalement l'on utilise des corticoïdes
depuis longtemps c'est notre décision à
nous on va décider ce qu'on veut
mais c'est pas la peine de le tester les
anglais ont testé correctement qu'à
contrôler c'est à des gens qui n'ont pas
reçu ont montré une mortalité plus
faible et ceux qui recevaient pas
résultat maintenant à peu près tout le
monde et reçoit des exams états aux
stéroïdes
alors partout dont la france qui n'en
donnait que de temps en temps selon
l'humeur du réanimateur et ça ça montre
vraiment le pragmatisme britannique par
rapport à certain dogmatisme et un
certain chaos français pour faire de la
recherche médicale mercy matin par don
médian la vie je vous en prie par contre
pour diminuer la charge virale
c'est-à-dire bloquer le développement il
ya effectivement un ah si tu pouvais
restent hors de l'île où je travaille
un médicament qui a été commandée
repositionner et dans review cet après
midi tous les résultats et je peux vous
dire que c'est vraiment très
impressionnant les résultats mais c'est
sur des cellules et maintenant va tester
ça chez des animaux et ensuite si c'est
positif faim chez des humains et l'idée
c'est de le tester
juste après la contamination ont
vraiment bloqué le développement de la
maladie qu'ovide dès ses débuts mais je
- les résultats de ce que j'ai vu
aujourd'hui me paraît vraiment
intéressant c'est quelque chose qui est
plus efficace mais hydroxy chloroquine
plus efficaces que leurs md y virent et
en plus c'est un médicament connu et qui
coûte rien et qui a pas d'effets
secondaires que et bien en tout cas on
suivra ça de près c'est merci beaucoup
philippe froguel d'avoir apporté votre
éclairage rappelle que vous êtes maître
de conférences en génétique professeur à
l'impérial collège de londres et à
l'université de lille et direction
l'espagne à présent où le premier
ministre espagnol pedro sanchez dévoile
son plan de relance pour redresser
l'économie espagnole 140 milliards
d'euros de fonds européens ont été
injectés pour faire face à la crise du
coc vide
les précisions à barcelone de l'es6
huit cent mille emplois en trois ans
c'est ce que prévoit de créer le
gouvernement espagnol
le premier ministre pedro sanchez a
annoncé son plan de relance prévu pour
six ans objectif développer une nouvelle
modernité pour le pays fortement impacté
par la crise du coc vite 19
alors ce plan rolland se compose de
quatre axes majeurs la transition
écologique qui représentera entière des
investissements la digitalisation qui
représentera un tiers également mais
aussi la cohésion sociale et
territoriale et l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes
alors pour ce faire le gouvernement
prévoit d'utiliser les 140 milliards
d'euros du fonds européen mais aussi
d'augmenter ses dépenses publiques de
53% alors si le gouvernement se montre
plutôt confiant les espagnols eux sont
plus pessimistes ils sont même plus
pessimiste qu'au début de la crise
financière de 2008
en effet leur vision de la situation
économique et du marché de l'emploi
s'assombrit il ya encore plus de 700
mille personnes au chômage partiel
depuis mars
les fermetures d'entreprise inquiète et
se succèdent d'ailleurs madrid et la
catalogne sont les régions les plus
touchées
et pour cette année 2020 le gouvernement
espagnol prévoit une chute du pib de 2
11% et bruxelles ferme ses bars et cafés
dès demain matin pour un mois objectif
freiner la propagation du coronavirus
alors que l'épidémie avait s'accélère
dans la capitale belge
cette décision concerne également les
salles de fêtes et les salons de thé en
revanche les restaurants peuvent rester
ouverts la belgique recense 2500
contamination par jour depuis une
semaine
le premier ministre s'est exprimé hier
soir sur la situation écouter la
situation dans notre pays est
préoccupante et elle est grave nous
voyons que quasiment partout dans notre
pays
le nombre des cas est en augmentation
nous voyons que le nombre
d'hospitalisations est en croissance et
nous voyons aussi que le nombre des
décès dans les hôpitaux est en hausse ou
si dans certains hôpitaux
la situation est vraiment critique nous
devons tout faire pour que la
propagation qui est en pleine
accélération maintenant pour arrêter
cela on fera tout pour éviter un nouveau
look down
mais en fait nous l'avons tous tout le
monde là dans ses mains si on ne
respecte pas les règles
on s'oriente vers les mesures encore
plus strictes et je pense que tout le
monde pas uniquement dans cette salle
tout le monde veut tout faire pour
éviter cette cette situation et dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de la
campagne présidentielle américaine avec
ce soir le débat entre les colistiers
kamala harris et mike pence avons occupé
cette fois le devant de la scène
puis direction le haut karabagh selon le
ministère azerbaïdjanais
une réunion de médiation internationale
se tiendra ce jeudi à genève alors que
les combats se poursuivent
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que les chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme
c'est quoi le taux de fiabilité du
projet ne serait ce qu'au business et on
oscille entre 92 et 98 5%
elle fonctionne bien ça permet un d'être
rapide d'être non invasif et puis
d'avoir le résultat de façon instantanée
avec un coût qui est quand même bien
moindre plus que sur les coûts actuels
du pcr on va pas sauver l'humanité
souffrent pour révolutionner les choses
avec le travail qu'on fait aux peut-être
faire en sorte qu fasse appel à savoir
faire qui à savoir faire médical aussi
dans un domaine un peu différente et
celui de l'animal mais après tout
l'homme c'est un animal populo
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même le
secteur de l'immobilier n'a pas été
épargnés par les mesures sanitaires
d'urgence mis en place par le
gouvernement les banques aujourd'hui
donc on sait qu'elles vont un peu coupé
les robinets et si elle coupe les
robinets ça va être un petit peu plus
compliqué pour l'immobilier l'immobilier
haut de gamme était la valeur refuge par
excellence celle qu'un qui a plus de 75
ans a priori il achète pas un
appartement il le vent et comme il aura
pas beaucoup de retraite
il est assez probable qu'ils soient
obligés de vendre son actif pour
continuer à vivre
il ya un vieillissement de la population
qui fait que vous allez avoir une baisse
des prix dit aujourd'hui que c'est la
revanche des campagnes contre les villes
parce que les villes souffrent
globalement tout le marché comme disait
lledo va devenir plus raisonnable les
acquéreurs vont être plus sélectifs
[Musique]
bandol comberge vous avez découvert que
l'imagerie médicale qui était le coeur
de votre métier avait une dimension
artistique me suis aperçu que c'était
l'art qui faisait avancer la science et
la science qui faisait la banque c'est
là l'image est belle mais mais en
général le mal qu'elle révèle
il est terrifiant au moment du coc vite
quand j'ai attrapé moi même la maladie
je me suis dit mais pourquoi j'utilise
pas ma technique de droite et de virton
life art pour mon thorax propres et pour
le virus j'ai pu suivre son évolution
comment voyez ça s'aggravait ou au
contraire comment ça s'évacue et quand
on a découvert le coït on sait qu on
sait comment ils et comment
quelle couleur il est qu'on a découvert
le mal l'e mail du mal
[Musique]
oh
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que les chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme c'est quoi le
taux de fiabilité du projet ne serait ce
qu'au business et on oscille entre 92 et
98 points 5 % elle fonctionne bien ça
permet un d'être rapide d'être non
invasif et puis d'avoir le résultat de
façon instantanée avec un coût qui est
quand même bien moindre plus que sont
les coûts actuels du pc on va pas sauver
l'humanité souffrent pour révolutionner
les choses avec le travail qu'on fait
aux peut-être fait en sorte qu fasse
appel à un savoir-faire que savoir-faire
médical aussi dans un domaine un peu
différente et celui de l'animal mais
après tout l'homme c'est un animal peu
plus tôt
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france
immunes ou rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française la campagne présidentielle
américaine ce soir c'est au tour des
numéros 2 de débattre les colistiers
kamala harris et mike pence le prochain
débat entre les deux candidats ce sera
le 15 octobre et donald trump tout juste
sorti de l'hôpital a hâte de retrouver
joe biden son adversaire démocrate lui
se montre plus prudent
je pense que s'il a toujours le coc vide
nous ne devrions pas faire ce débat et à
ce propos je pense que nous allons
devoir suivre des directives très
strictes trop de personnes ont été
infectées et c'est un problème très
sérieux
c'est un cinglé depuis des années et
tout le monde le sait les médias se
retrouvent coincés avec lui et essaye
juste de le protéger
avez vous remarqué que toutes les choses
négatives comme son très faible qi ne
sont plus jamais mentionné faye curieuse
les états unis où les négociations sont
à l'arrêt entre démocrates et
républicains au sujet du plan de soutien
à l'économie
un processus santé censée venir en aide
aux ménages et aux entreprises
grégoire hotz l'aide aux américains les
plus en difficulté attendre à des
négociations plus un plan daide à
l'arrêt l'annnonce de donald trump sur
twitter ce mardi et a provoqué un
véritable coup de tonnerre pour
l'économie américaine nancy pelosi
demande 2,4 milliards de dollars pour
renflouer les états démocrate mal géré
et à forte criminalité
une somme qui n'a rien à voir avec le co
vie 19
nous avons fait une offre très généreuse
de 1,6 milliard de dollars
et comme d'habitude elle ne négocie pas
de bonne foi
je rejette leur demande et je me tourne
vers l'avenir de notre pays
j'ai demandé à mes représentants
d'arrêter de négocier en attendant les
élections
lorsqu immédiatement après ma victoire
nous adopterons en important projet de
loi de stimulation qui se concentrera
sur les américains qui travaillent dur
et sur les petites entreprises
en plus d'une chute de la bourse à wall
street le locataire de la maison blanche
et les républicains se sont attiré les
foudres des ténors du parti démocrate
c'est malheureux car il a abandonné nos
enfants
nous avons de si bonnes dispositions
dans le projet de loi
ils n'étaient pas d'accord sur tout mais
nous étions sur une lancée il a
abandonné nos travailleurs et ce que
nous devons faire pour les familles de
travailleurs américains
ne vous y trompez pas si vous n'avez pas
l'emploi si votre entreprise est fermé
si l'école de votre enfant est fermé si
vous voyez des licenciements autour de
vous donald trump a décidé aujourd'hui
que rien de tout cela absolument rien ne
lui apporter si le grand plan de soutien
est reporté le président américain
annonce toutefois d'autres aides partiel
avant les élections la chambre et le
sénat devrait approuver immédiatement 25
milliards de dollars pour le soutien des
salaires des compagnies aériennes et 135
milliards de dollars pour le programme
de protection des salaires des petites
entreprises
ces deux montants seront entièrement
payés avec les fonds non utilisés du
premier plan daide obtenir cet argent et
je le signerai tout de suite la campagne
américaine va donc à nouveau son plein
alors que donald trump vient tout juste
de quitter l'hôpital quelques jours
après avoir contracté le coronavirus et
pour parler de cette campagne américaine
nous sommes en direct depuis tombent pas
aux états unis avec eric 'lion'
consultant international c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
eric 'lion' bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors le
débat entre les colistiers a lieu dans
quelques heures maintenant qu'on attende
les américains est ce qu'ils en
attendent plus de fonds après le premier
duel entre un peu ébahi donne un plaisir
d'être ici je vous appelle effectivement
de tampa en floride
c'est une région très hautement discuter
des élections c'est ce qu'on appelle un
état qui vaut que doivent avoir avec un
tueur cette région indique quel état
d'esprit dans le pays ce qu'on attend du
débat dans cette région dans ce pays si
c'est d'entendre les perspectives des
colistiers de savoir si bien travaillé
avec le candidat présidentiel
je pense qu'il sera très intéressant de
suivre ce débat que nous pourrons
apprendre beaucoup et qui a le plus à
perdre selon vous kamala harris ou bien
mike pence
je pense que kamala harris toile se
trouvait je suis en tant que jeune
sénatrice qui n'a passé que quelques
années à un poste et lui confirme il
disant moins 10 ans d'expérience le
congrès a déjà plusieurs années
d'expérience en tant que vice-président
en plus de son mandat tamedia mais si on
veut comparer l'été ni de l'indiana
c'est une grosse partie du pib de
l'irlande
kamal un risque beaucoup plus faire ses
preuves que mike pence alors une
campagne bien évidemment marquée par la
crise sanitaire par le coronavirus
maïten ce soir ne veut pas de barrière
en plexiglas autour de lui alors du
débat est-ce que cela ça vous surprend
cela vous surprendre en contexte actuel
et surtout par rapport aux tests
positifs de donald trump
c'est une question extrêmement
intéressante de ce document de
protection personnelle des mesures mises
en place pour empêcher la contagion le
soutien aux états unis
nous avons passé six à sept mois à
porter nos masques rapporté nous en
parler des mesures de protection des
écrans je pense que les gens ne sont pas
convaincus pour le moulin avec que ces
équipements sont nécessaires et si et
matin je ne veux pas d'un écran alors
cela reflète l'état d'esprit des gens
tels que je peut l'observer tous les
jours les gens sont las de ces
restrictions
ils ne voient pas la crise le président
a été testé positif au virus la première
dame et d'autres hauts gradés également
et ils ont constaté que la guérison
était très rapide qu'il n'y a pas eu de
catastrophe
effectivement je ne pense pas qu'il y
aura des écrans ce soir mais ce sera
intéressant à tous les cas alors sur le
plan économique donald trump on n'en
parlait a rompu les négociations avec
les démocrates sur un plan de soutien à
l'économie
comment est-ce qu'on peut le comprendre
dans quel but
ce qu'il faut selon vous effectivement
repoussé ce plan après la présidentielle
du 3 novembre et pourquoi qui pensaient
que lors d'une année électorale à chaque
événement de l'importance a passé 26 ans
en ligne
je suis rentré aux états unis anthony 18
en floride et j'y ai retrouvé la
meilleure économie que j'avais jamais
connue de ma vie
hop un jour de février les grands
savions une économie florissante et puis
le coronavirus l'a fait décrocher même
s'il espère 50 influencer l'économie de
façon qu'on n'aurait pas pu lâcher des
sénateurs sont fermées des bars
peut-être que les mesures étaient
pertinentes je ne suis pas scientifique
je ne peux pas vous dire si c'est
vraiment le cas
au cumul mais l'atout lemieux confiante
ifi qui ont même rejoint au score la
première est passée d'un taux de 3 % de
chômage a presque 14% je pense depuis au
cours des mois je sais on est retombé à
8 4 9% donc l'économie reste solide
nelly électorale
tout est lié à l'élection si le
président négocié avec même si elle
aussi sur un programme
de la situation pourrait évoluer d'une
façon organique à laquelle aucun d'eux
ne s'attendait d'avancé voilà je pense
que l'économie est forte at il ajouté
les gens veulent retrouver le travail
la copie 19 est une véritable tragédie
notamment pour les petits commerces ont
renforcé et construit l'homme d'affaires
couach deux décennies qui ont tout perdu
suite à la réaction à la cofidis 9
merci beaucoup eric 'lion' d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes consultant international
nouveaux affrontements dans la région du
haut karabagh où l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan s'affrontent depuis une
semaine et demie des combats qui
continuent malgré les nombreuses
pressions internationales une réunion de
médiation sur le sujet est prévue demain
à genève tu es au combat
la situation au karabagh mais la
communauté internationale dans
l'embarras le conflit en est ce mercredi
à son onzième jour et ne semble pas
baisser en intensité dans la nuit de
mardi à mercredi
les combats ont de nouveau fait rage
entre l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie qui ont
chacun multiplié les bombardements dans
la province séparatiste
une situation qui inquiète l'union
européenne nous avons reçu des rapports
extrêmement inquiétant en faisant état
d'une recrudescence des attaques sur les
zones peuplées qui font des victimes
parmi les civils
nous demandons instamment aux parties de
respecter pleinement leurs obligations
internationales en matière de protection
des populations civiles
un cessez-le-feu également réclamée par
le groupe de minsk
créé en 1992 lors de la première guerre
du haut karabagh un groupe qui compte
notamment comme coprésidents paris
moscou ou encore washington en consensus
se dégage donc au sein de la communauté
internationale pour un règlement
pacifique du conflit
seule exception la turquie ali fervents
de l'azerbaïdjan m l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan sur un pied d'égalité
reviens tard des compensées l'occupant
le monde doit soutenir ceux qui sont
dans leur bon droit
nommément l'azerbaïdjan une implication
turque dans le conflit qui inquiète le
chef de la diplomatie française jean
yves le drian
la nouveauté c'est qu'il ya une
implication militaire de la turquie qui
risque d'alimenter
l'internationalisation du conflit
je déplore un nombre important de
victimes civiles pour des avancées
territoriale faible de la part de
l'azerbaïdjan
puisque c'est l'azerbaïdjan qui a initié
le conflit il y aura des réunions demain
genève d'autres lundi à moscou et nous
formulons le voeu que cela puisse
aboutir à l'ouverture de négociations
des négociations qui reste pour
l'instant à l'état de projet
selon le médiateur de la république
autoproclamée du haut karabagh
et de la moitié de la population de la
province a été déplacées en raison des
combats
elle a réussi également très préoccupée
par le conflit dans l'ohl dans le
haut-karabagh on en parle avec notre
correspondant russie en punk les roues
les efforts diplomatiques de la
communauté internationale y compris deux
moscou reste pour l'heure sans effet la
mire poutine s'est d'ailleurs exprimé
sur le sujet à l'occasion d'une
interview diffusée sur une des chaînes
du service public russe il expliquait
que ce conflit était un véritable crève
coeur pour la russie qui se sont aussi
proches de l'azerbaïdjan que de
l'arménie et où vivent de très nombreux
ressortissants de ces deux pays
proposent d'écouter son intervention à
cause de ce match tout comme vous le
savez l'arménie est membre de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective
nous avons certaines obligations envers
l'arménie en vertu de ce traité
mais les hostilités à notre grand regret
se poursuivent toujours
et cela ne se passe pas en territoire
arménien quant au respect par la russie
de ses obligations en vertu de ce traité
nous les avons toujours remplies nous
les remplissons et nous continuerons de
les remplir
comme vous le savez le vide en contact
permanent avec le premier ministre
arménien et les dirigeants arméniens
note aucun doute quant au respect par la
russie de ses obligations dans le cadre
du traité on l'a entendu le président
russe a évoqué l'organisation du traité
de sécurité collective qui lie entre
autres la russie et l'arménie
celui ci inclut une clause de solidarité
dans le cas d'une attaque extérieure
mais tant que le conflit ne concerne que
le haut karabagh et pas l'arménie en
elle-même alors le traité ne s'applique
pas reste donc la diplomatie vladimir
poutine s'est par exemple entretenu dans
la journée avec le président
azerbaïdjanais ilham aliyev le dialogue
entre les belligérants et le rôle d'un
médiateur comme celui de la russie reste
donc pour l'heure le meilleur espoir de
voir cesser les combats à la région
disputée du haut karabagh toujours
pas de répit dans les affrontements
entre les forces arméniennes et
azerbaïdjanaises alors qu'elle
diplomatie pour sortir de ce conflit
elle c'est l'objet de notre face à face
ce soir et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec gunnell safarova présidente de
l'association au dialogue france
azerbaïdjan bonsoir à vos côtés franck
papazian coprésident du ccfc conseil de
coordination des organisations
arméniennes de france bonsoir alors la
france
on l'a dit affirme ce soir que la
turquie est impliquée militairement dans
ce conflit aux côtés de l'azerbaïdjan
que répondez-vous guisnel safarova 7
déclarations du ministre des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian c'est la
turquie qui est à la base de ces
troubles
p je pense que ça a été dit clairement
en plusieurs reprises par les chefs
d'état de l'azerbaïdjan est de la
turquie et par rapport en fin par
d'autres officiels que l'azerbaïdjan et
la turquie
enfin la turquie apporte un soutien
moral politique et diplomatique à
l'azerbaïdjan et dans aucun cas on
parlait de soutien militaire et donc il
n'y a rien pas déduit lithaire de la
turquie en azerbaïdjan d'une façon
l'azerbaïdjan n'a pas besoin des deux
militaires ni de la turquie n'est
d'autre payer car il a assez de deux
forces armées azerbaïdjanaises il ya
plus de cent mille personnes donc il n'a
pas eu notre dead
donc l'armée d'azerbaïdjan est assez
forte pour défendre et pour amener le
compte trois offensives dans les
territoires de l'azerbaïdjan
franck papazian que répondez-vous à
lunel safarova justement sur cette
absence de
militaires turcs en azerbaïdjan selon
hugues une aile safarova
aujourd'hui tout le monde ne sait que
l'offensive est stimulé affaires de
gamme de prix en la république turque
qui force qui stimule qui encourage
l'azerbaïdjan à lancer des offensives
militaires depuis des années contre
l'arménie
on sait aujourd'hui que 400 djihadistes
des supplétifs à l'armée turque ont été
envoyés en azerbaïdjan on sait qu'il ya
105 ans experts militaires qui sont
allés à la manoeuvre à bakou pour
coordonner pour diriger la manoeuvre
militaire contre l'armée nuit on sait
que erdogan ladhuie lui-même
nous sommes un seul peuple et deux états
et erdogan a dit on va terminer le
travail
donc effectivement l'implication de la
turquie au côté de l'azerbaïdjan ne fait
aucun doute
le gouvernement français l'eau et c'est
eux le conseil de sécurité des nations
unies a reconnu que l'azerbaïdjan avait
initié cette attaque bombardé
populations civiles et les arméniens ne
font que se défendre face à une armée
d'occupation qui a pour objectif de
massacrer les aryens dur à la barre de
prendre leur al-ahmar et la turquie
souhaite également occupé le sud de
l'arménie
on est dans le cas d'un grand plan très
dangereux qui va mettre le feu aux
poudres de la région du caucase mais
aussi du moyen-orient et qui serait une
plaie pour le monde il faut absolument
arrêter l'azerbaïdjan il faut que
l'azerbaïdjan avec ses enfants si
criminelle contre l'arménie qui ne le
vends un calibre en tête d'une al-saffar
au revoir on l'entendait et on constate
une escalade de violence inquiet qui est
dangereux c'est indéniable menace pour
la stabilité de la région à ce que un
cessez le feu est possible selon vous on
sait qu'il ya une réunion de médiation
internationale sur la situation qui est
prévue qui a été annoncé à jeu
mev pour jeudi je veux juste envie de
rajouter une chose que la serre voiture
mais l'opération du contre-offensive
donc à plusieurs reprises il avait de la
provocation de la part de l'arménie
le premier ministre de l'arménie qui est
déclarée les annonces dans les
territoires occupés de l'azerbaïdjan
locales et amélia points et il avait en
fait une investiture du chef de soi
disant république et ces deux rues la
chocha après ils ont décidé de
transférer le parlement du soi-disant
république achats
plusieurs faits à billes arméniens du
liban qui étaient installés dans le haut
karabagh y compris à choucha qui est un
ancien ville de l'azerbaïdjan ça c'est
une crime de guerre et cela est
totalement contraire de la convention de
genève il est le patron historique de
l'azerbaïdjan qui efface et le monument
était la fabrique qui sont détruits et
l'azerbaïdjan actuellement enfin
l'azerbaïdjan il a il amène une
opération de contre offensive ton qu'il
a dit là il a toujours répondu ah enfin
il a juste répondu euros à la
provocation
il défend l'azerbaïdjan défends
simplement les intérêts il soutient sa
position et il mène donc à une mais sa
politique et le tout le monde le monde a
tiré connais le haut karabagh confessant
partie intégrante de l'azerbaïdjan
toutes les organisations internationales
reconnaisse l'intégrité territoriale de
l'azerbaïdjan
tous les pays du monde et leur
reconnaisse l'intégrité de la rupture de
l'azerbaïdjan et depuis presque trente
ans les résolutions leucate résolution
de l'onu qui reste sur le papier et
depuis presque trente ans des
négociations sont menées dans le cadre
du groupe de minsk et qui est chaque
fois on fait régulièrement ils étaient
vingt l'arménie les pommiers à des
provocations qui sont paralysés qui
paralyse et les professeurs on va
écouter franck papazian qui va vous
répondre justement sur cette terre du
haut karabakh pour voiler historiquement
arménienne
rabat arménienne a été attribués à
staline par staline à l'azerbaïdjan en
1921 ce que madame oublie de dire c'est
qu'à la fin des années 80 et au début
des années 90 en fait
l'azerbaïdjan a massacré d arménia kg
abad h au chi à mener la guerre contre
les arméniens et en 1994 un cessez le
feu est instauré sous des auspices du
groupe de minsk de loi c e et depuis
1994 c'est à dire depuis 26 ans
l'azerbaïdjan violent si 1000 à 10000
fois par an le cessez-le-feu en
contravention et toutes les normes de
droit international en 2016
elle a contracté une guerre la guerre
des quatre jours en mois de juillet le
12 juillet elle a agressé militairement
l'armée ni la république l'a de
l'arménie donc est une république
reconnu par la communauté internationale
est là depuis le 27 septembre
elle mène des offensives de grande
envergure contre l'arménie dans le laps
de temps le peuple du karabakh c'est
comme ces poteaux déterminé dans le
cadre d'un référendum
d'autodétermination
ce peuple là ne retournera jamais son
administration de l'azerbaïdjan parce
que l'azerbaïdjan a massacré les
arméniens à la fin des années 80 au
début des années 90
donc ça oubliez il n'en est pas question
les arméniens veulent vivre en paix
d'accord il l'azerbaïdjan est une menace
pour les arméniens pendant ce temps
madame devrait comprendre une chose
c'est que l'offensive actuelle est
condamné par la communauté
internationale qui a reconnu que
l'azerbaïdjan était l'agresseur laser
belles jantes bombardé population subit
les arméniens ne faut ne font que se
défendre et il est important aujourd'hui
pour éviter des massacres dans la région
que la communauté internationale prenne
ses responsabilités des négociations où
le demain à genève se poursuivre lundi à
moscou
et je pense qu'il est temps de faire
entendre raison à l'azerbaïdjan et à son
allié turc du globe
ça va on va assécher il faut quelqu'un
conditions pour un cessez le feu
aujourd'hui
deux choses les fameuses décision du 5
juillet 1921 il et il n'avait pas du
tout il avait il faut faire attention
aux mots c'est mais par attachement ni
transfert c'étaient les liens partant de
nécessité de la paix et les liens
économiques entre le karabagh supérieur
et intérieurs à inférieur lé lien
constant avec l'azerbaïdjan c'était
maintenir le haut karabagh en république
soviétique d'azerbaïdjan en lui
conférant d'une large autonomie
régionale maintenir il faut faire
attention l'ombre qui ont utilisé mais
par attachement ni transfert c'est
maintien c'est pour mr chose
deuxièmement on parle par rapport au
fait que les cibles les forces
séparatistes et des par l'arménie
actuellement cible des installations et
de son peuple et qui se trouve en dehors
voire très très loin de la zone
je peux parler de genji oeil qui est
soit 5 km de long il a même réseau qui a
à peu près à côté de capital à bas coût
et il y avait des unis rogner elle avait
parmi les blessés on trouve aussi en une
une arménien il perd en fait tu veux
juste préciser qu'il ya actuellement
trente mille arméniens qui habite
toujours à l'azerbaïdjan franck papazian
voulez sur le mot de la fin il reste
malheureusement que quelques secondes
franck papazian pour conclure qu est ce
qu il faudrait quelles conditions
aujourd'hui pour que finalement un
cessez-le-feu soit possible il faut que
l'azerbaïdjan contrainte que le karabakh
n'est pas un territoire azerbaïdjanais
c'est un territoire historique arméniens
qui habité par des arméniens qui veulent
vivre en paix il faut laisser les
arméniens vivre en paix d'accord on veut
pas qu'on peut pas vivre à nouveau
génocide en 1920 comme nous l'avons vécu
en 1915 or les asservir année sont des
agresseurs c'est un un état qui veut la
guerre et l'arménie veut la paix ça
suffit maintenant il faut votre discours
madame est incompréhensible inaudible ou
de france est ce que tu es un gros grain
si on parle de la paix lazare bâtie
neuve ou le la paix et si vous parlez de
la gymnastique on peut parler aussi
génocide de regarder qui était combien
1980 on va devoir fixer dans le temps
qui nous est imparti se termine en tout
cas merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté ce débat dans ce contexte de
grande tension
on le sait merci à vous guisnel safarova
je rappelle que vous êtes président
de l'association au dialogue france
azerbaïdjan et merci à vous franck
papazian
je rappelle que vous êtes co président
du conseil de coordination des
organisations arméniennes de france et
c'est la fin de cette émission on va se
retrouver dans quelques instants dans un
peu moins de cinq minutes pour 1 point
complet sur l'actualité rester avec nous
sur rt france
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service